[Music]
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans
checking back in from my apartment with
a very exciting update
it is time to get back to business baby
that's right
the season 12 hot ones hot sauce reveal
now i know what you're thinking on the
other side of the camera there you're
thinking
hey sean you're in your home how in the
world are you going to do these episodes
well to start we're going to do them
over the internet like we did with burke
cricher and as things evolve
we'll follow suit and get back to the
old look and feel and trust me when i
say this
no one wants to get back to the studio
more than me
the second we can get back to the studio
we are going back to the studio
obviously things are a little bit
complicated right now but trust me when
i say that
the second we get back to the studio we
are going to be in the studio
and that is a sean evans promise i'm
going crazy in here
until then though the same interviews
you know and love same goofy format
all new season which means new sauces
before we get into all that though i do
want to say something i think it'd be
wrong if i didn't say something
black lives matter to hot ones and i
don't think it's enough to assume that
everyone knows this so let's just put
that out there going into the new season
it's always been a goal of ours as goofy
as the show is on paper
it's always been the goal to bring
people from all walks of life
into the studio sit them down at the
table and have a very real conversation
over spicy wings
and we owe so much of our success over
the years to black culture
from the guests to the endless questions
about rap lyrics
uh down to many of the pop culture touch
points that make up the dna of the show
things that are created and popularized
by black people
to the fact that tony ayo from g-unit
did the first episode
and told us that we were doing it wrong
he's like you guys got to eat the wings
too
so back when hot ones was just uh an
idea and like an
email someplace it was like tony yo that
really helped us get that plane off of
the ground
so without that moment without hip hop
there's no hot ones it's just a part of
our origin story since the beginning the
foundation
literally since the first episode
without black culture there's no hot
ones
without black culture there's no pop
culture which is why it drives me
totally insane when people complain
about rappers being on the show since
it's so much a part of what we've been
doing
since the first episode and i mean this
when i say it
i'll put our fans up against anybody on
the internet some of the smartest most
thoughtful fans i'll put our fans
up against anybody's and that's why i'm
hoping that if you see that in the
comments
that you pointed out or if you see
casual racism in your life
you call it out that's the hope for me
that's the hope for you
that's the hope for us going into season
12
and speaking of season 12 it is time to
break down
the hot ones hot sauce lineup and
starting off in the lead-off spot it's
the classic
with a blue label like many great things
in life this sauce was born from a
mistake
when a batch of the classic was
accidentally mixed with 10 times the
amount of garlic in the recipe
oops but it turns out it was delicious
and after tinkering with the formula
mixing in some sweet fresno peppers a
big punch of garlic
bam classic garlic fresno was born
all right moving on to the two spot at
number two it's steel city jade jaguar
if you watch the show you know i have a
soft spot for canadian hot sauces
this one is right out of ontario as a
rich oil base that just
sets the stage for a zesty trio of
jalapenos
garlic and lime delicious all right
moving on to number three it's fresno
sauce companies chipotle and habanero
this la native right here this sauce
custom made for the hot ones three spot
it lures you in with fruity habanero and
savory garlic and then
right when you're in the middle of an
anecdote it smacks you in the face with
a lingering dose of heat in chipotle
smoke
all right moving on to number four the
grim reaper raises his sickle and
beckons on the label of hotter-than-el
ghost sauce
this right here is out of jacksonville
florida a very fresh-tasting sauce
you have carrots you have tomatoes
farmer's market ingredients
but don't be fooled they don't put the
grim reaper on a bottle for nothing
a healthy dose of ghost pepper very
strong number four
in our setup for the halfway point los
calientes rojo
you already know the vibe it's like los
calientes but it's red
applewood smoked jalapenos citrus and a
handful of habaneros to crank up the
volume a little bit
the perfect pairing for the internet's
most beloved instagram deep dives
all right moving on to the sixth spot
kicking off the back half at seafire
gourmet reaper and for those of you
keeping score at home
this is now the second bottle that we've
had in the lineup with the grim reaper
holding a sickle on it
and we are only on sauce number six now
if you've been around here
you know that you have to respect the
carolina reaper i know i give the
carolina reaper a lot of respect
but in this sauce you have this sting
and it's balanced out
with barbecue honey and brown sugar if
that doesn't sound good i don't know
what does
all right now we're moving on to the
number seven spot it's no joke here at
number seven
for our new number seven we head to
nebraska it's volcanic peppers thor's
hammer
you know we love a good viking over here
at first we feast
and this sauce right here it drops the
hammer on your taste buds with a
potentially lethal combination
of seven pot peppers and chocolate ghost
sure to put our guests
up against the ropes and then we have a
knockout punch
the bomb beyond insanity holds down its
legacy position in the eight spot
whether or not sending this sauce
through the mail to celebrities homes
will result in any legal repercussions
i guess only time will tell i've said it
before i'll say it again
from my cold dead hands the bomb beyond
insanity
holds its place in the lineup it is our
old glory
and she stays all right we got a new
number nine
our new number nine is monoloco pierre
de almost and we're super excited about
this one
our first sauce out of costa rica this
sauce right here will knock you off your
perch in the canopy and leave you face
down on the rainforest floor
the big citrus flavor and heat they come
from panamanian peppers
ghost chilies garlic and spices lemon
an awesome sauce very complex very hot
and speaking of very hot it's the last
dab xxx holding down the 10 spot
some traditions stay this is one of them
the last dab
xxx closing out our lineup and here it
is
in all of its glory the hot ones season
12 lineup
and when we do a reveal you know that
episodes are just around the corner
hot one season 12 premieres june 25th
that's right june 25th mark your
calendars hot ones is back
baby thank you so much for your support
over now five years
11 seasons on to 12. i have missed you
so much
i love you thank you for your support
thank you for being patient
and we will see you again on june 25th
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in
with a very exciting hot one sub box
announcement
if you are not already subscribed july
is the month to do it
why because you will be the first person
to get the classic
garlic fresno edition which will be
featured in july's box
along with two other sauces from some of
our favorite makers
the sauce is like a brighter more
natural sriracha with no sugar and sub
box base is limited so if you're on the
fence
do not wait and i know what you're
thinking at home what if i just want the
sauce
it'll go on sale later in july but first
look
goes to sub box subscribers heatness.com
heatness.com to sign up the classic
fresno garlic edition around here we
call it the blue label